the nun tells the origin story of the
demon Ballack littered throughout the
conjuring series the demonic nun has
proven to be a thorn in the side of
those who fight for good and her
backstory has remained a mystery until
now throughout this video I will be
discussing the plot of the nun as well
as the film's ending there will be heavy
spoilers so it may be worth skipping
this video for now if you want to go in
with fresh eyes with that out the way
I'm definition and high ruin the movie
so you don't have to after the
mysterious suicide of a nun had the
Carter monastery priest Father Burke and
new practice in nun are sent to
investigate arriving at the monastery
the to discover some unorthodox things
about the worshippers there that hint at
the fact that all is not what it seems
that you all discovered that the castle
was previously owned by a mysterious man
named the Duke and he used that to
summon dark forces and open a hole to
hell aware of this the church intervened
and sealed the hole to hell by using a
special flask that contained Jesus's
blood
however this hole was reopened after a
bombing in World War two which is why
evil forces began to take over the
castle once more sister Irene
investigates she interacts with nuns
throughout the monastery this triggers a
vision that instructs the sister to
follow the Virgin Mary in order to find
the blood of Christ which can reseal the
hole the investigators with the help of
a man named Frenchy go on their quest
however Irene becomes separated and
faces danger at every turn
Ballack stalks and attempts to take over
her body in order to leave the confines
of the monastery during an attack we
realized that the other nuns who were
inhabited
monestary were in fact spirits put there
to draw in the soon-to-be nun to become
a host for the demon valley sister Irene
manages to spit the blood of Christ into
bollocks face which he believes kills
the demon once and for all
however this is a guise and instead
VALIC transfers into Frenchie as he is a
world traveler this will give the demon
free reign over the earth we learn that
he has Ballack inside of him due to the
fact that he has an upside-down cross
embedded on the back of his neck similar
to the one that bellick tried to put on
Irene earlier in the film this is a
motif of the conjuring franchise as
demons often mark or attempt to mock
those that they seek to control we then
see footage of an exorcism performed by
the Warrens in which they inadvertently
free the demon from frenchie or in turn
put it into the mother from the
conjuring they're setting the events
that happen in that film a prequel based
around a character that appears later in
the series was never going to have a
scene in which they were defeated but
even so the nun still managed to
surprise me with his ending it
beautifully ties into the series and
highlights just how strong the demon
VALIC is it's a nice twist that doesn't
ruin the films that preceded it as
prequels often do I think the film's
definitely worth your time if you're a
fan of the series so what did you think
of the non-man how would you rank it
amongst the rest of the series and what
would you like to see next comment below
and let me know and if you enjoyed this
video please like it and subscribe to my
channel I create content like this
weekly and I'll definitely be something
on here that you love if you're a fan of
film recently I discussed the ending of
searching so make sure you check that
video out next linked at the end of this
one again thanks very much for taking
the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
you